so what I thought I'd show was some of
the simulations that we've done on
within our research group here at
Leicester so this is an image here of
the milky white this is real data so
this is taken with a large number of
different telescopes what you can see
here is the the disk of the Milky Way
the central bright region is the Bulge
of the Milky Way and some of the
satellite galaxies so that for example
there is the Large Magellanic Cloud and
if we zoom in on the central bit so just
on this central square roughly 6 million
years ago there were some new stars
formed at the very center of the Milky
Way because we can see those at the
present time and we know they're about 6
million years old so a few years ago we
asked the question what would happen if
some gas that was involved in the
process of forming those stars fell onto
the black hole at the centre of the
Milky Way so we know that there's a very
massive black hole it's about 4 million
times the mass of our Sun so it's very
heavy and when gas falls onto a black
hole like that a lot of radiation is
released so we wanted to know what would
happen when that radiation hit the gas
that surrounds the Milky Way and what
you see here is at the centre of the
Milky Way we have the gas falling onto
the black hole and this is the gas
around the Milky Way the density of it
and the temperature of it and what you
can see is that as a result of this
small amount of energy that was input at
the very center you blow this huge
bubble around the galaxy and if we were
running a simulation of the lower part
of the galaxy we'd see the same thing
the disk of the Milky Way is here and
the reason why this is interesting is we
live about there so somewhere between 7
and 8,000 parsecs from the center of the
Milky Way and as you can see even though
the black hole is only at the very very
center it's able to produce effects
which stretch all the way out to us and
Beyond and so one of the things we're
looking up now is to study that process
in more detail so this particular
simulation was done on the previous
generation of Dirac computers but we've
now started doing more detailed ones
focusing in on the very very central
so this is work that was done by one of
our current PhD students Morten born
using the direct to computer and this
time we start off with the gas looking
very clumpy because that's how we think
it would have looked at the time that
the milky way was forming what happens
when the energy is input into the gas is
it's much more complicated so it's much
more complex than just a nice simple
bubble moving out in some regions where
the gas was thinner the radiation and
gas and hot gas can move out very
quickly and in other regions it's able
to just compress the gas that's there
and some of it even falls back into the
black hole itself so what we've learned
from this simulation is the process of
feedback as we call it where gas falls
onto black hole and releases energy can
do two things we used to think it would
just prevent new stars from forming
because it would blow away all the
existing gas but we've seen from
simulations like this it can actually
force more gas to fall into the black
hole and keep that cycle going so it's
actually a system self-sustaining
process and this is work that's we're
currently doing further simulations and
the some of the jobs that you saw
running on the machine when we were in
the machine room some of them were doing
this kind of simulation and other work
by my student Claire Cashmore is also
looking at the impact of this on the
small galaxies around the Milky Way so
these kind of jobs would be impossible
to do on a normal desktop because they
would take so long to do each individual
run that we wouldn't be able to
understand what was going on because if
you think about it when you do one of
these runs we don't know exactly how the
galaxy looked in the past so we have to
make some assumptions and try something
see what the outcome is and then go back
to the beginning and say okay what would
happen if we changed it very slightly
now if it took two years to do each of
the runs we'd never be able to make any
progress and learn anything because we
could only ever do one simulation but
because we can use Dirac we're able to
do lots of these simulations so we can
explore a whole lot of different initial
conditions and then we can actually say
the Milky Way must have looked like this
in the past because we know that that's
the only way it would look through
in the present so it's kind of a very
much so so that's the the thing with
astronomy which makes it different from
many other subjects or any many other
types of science is we can't do
experiments like normal science can so
we have to we look at the universe as we
see it now we can look into the past
because we can see things that are far
away and the light from them has taken
millions or billions of years to reach
us so we're seeing galaxies near us as
they are now and far away from us as
they were a long time in the past but
what we can't do is take the Milky Way
and turn it upside down and look at it
from the other side we can only look at
it from where we're sitting and so what
we have to do then instead is we use
supercomputers they're like doing
experiments but for astronomy and we
build galaxies and these galaxies that
we're building we can look at them from
any angle that we want to and we can
change how the physics is incorporated
into these galaxies and then we can see
do they look anything like the galaxies
that we see in the real universe if they
do then we can say okay we think we
understand how galaxies work but if they
don't then we can go back and say well
if all galaxies are bigger than the ones
that we find in our simulations or all
galaxies are much smoother than the
image that we see here then we can say
there's something wrong with our
simulation we need to do something
different we need to change some some of
our assumptions and so we mentioned
three what's next and how long will that
take together
so Derek 3 is what we're hoping will be
the new system and we're hoping that
will be supported at some point in the
next couple of years so we're currently
in a process of designing what what we
would need based on our science that
we're going to try and do in the next
five years and so we're very much hoping
that we'll be supported in putting this
together
yes bigger better different and it's
going in our current vision of it it has
new services so it has a data service
which
very focused on problems where not only
are we doing big simulations but we're
comparing them to very large
observational data sets so that's with a
view to modeling data coming from
satellites like the Gaia satellite that
was launched in at the end of 2013 so
it's had it there's been a long
tradition of doing theoretical
astrophysics and particle physics in the
UK so there was already there's been a
very long history of people doing these
kind of simulations and originally it
was individual centers were would have
their own computers so for example
Leicester 15 years ago had its own
computer cluster and then it set up what
was called the UK Astrophysical fluids
facility which was a national facility
for people doing simulations of gas
flows on various different scales and
the so that system was a national
facility but was still housed at
Leicester and for a long time all the
research of this coin was done on
individual group machines and then some
of the groups would apply for time on
big international facilities or national
facilities in the UK and what we
realized in 2008 and 2009 was that we
could get much more science out if we
could have machines that were a bit
bigger and more powerful than the
machines that an individual group could
have but we didn't want to put all the
money into one system because different
scientific problems need different
computer architectures so one big system
wouldn't be optimal for the kind of
science that we're doing so that's why
we decided to in 2009 we had a large set
of machines so Derek one was a set of
machines which was essentially larger
versions of what everybody already had
with a view to direct to consolidating
into the five machines that we have now
and so there was a process whereby we
worked out over those three years from
2009 to 2012
what were the
or architectures that we needed to have
indirect - and we're undergoing the same
process now in the hope that we'll be
able to upgrade to direct 3 at some
point in the next couple of years
and again the processes we're going
through or we've gone through our
science the science questions that we
work on to try and understand exactly
what architectures were going to need in
the future Derek - so the current system
cost we got 15 million pans for Hardware
so that was the original capital
investment from the Department of
Business Innovation and Skills and so
that was divided up among the various
machines the running costs are paid for
by STFC so that's the science and
technology facilities cancel as the
research canceled that funds research in
the UK for particle physics and for
astrophysics among other things and so
the running costs of it are about one
and a half million pounds a year and
that includes electricity and the staff
costs yes it does but the main and a key
aspect of Derek as well was the design
of the systems to use as little power as
possible so they are very efficient and
most importantly our data centers are
very are as efficient as they can be so
for example the one in Leicester is
passively cooled until the outside
temperature is above 19 degrees and even
then it's only when it gets about 24
degrees that it becomes a proper air
conditioning system below that it uses a
lot less power and so that means where
in the past the cooling of the of a
cluster would take a huge fraction of
its of its electricity in fact now we're
getting what's called a PUA of about 1.2
or less so that means for every unit of
electricity that we put into actually
running the computer we only use point
two of units two coolers and so that
means that we're doing our bit for the
environment as well it's it's a very
fine balance because you also want to
get as much so when the chips are
running at their full capacity there
using more power so there is an element
that we have to be as efficient as we
can and we're actually working on that
now to improve our codes because how you
write your software can also affect how
much electricity you use and in view of
the environmental impact of obviously
the use of electricity we're now looking
to make our software more energy
efficient in the sense that we'll be
looking at things like if you want to
write this to write a particular output
to disk that takes some extra
electricity is do you need to write it
out as often as you are doing and again
the length of the runs in the future we
imagine will one of the considerations
will not just be how many cores do we
have but how many kilowatts do we have
and how many how many units of
electricity are we prepared to spend on
on this bit of science there's a lot of
technology changes going on at the
moment in the on the hardware side so
for example there's a within many
computer systems you're seeing things
like many core systems becoming very
common so that's things like graphics
cards or the xeon phi cards and these
are very useful when you're doing big
calculations because they're very power
efficient but you've got to be able to
use them efficiently if you're going to
get the full compute power out of them
and so most of our codes at the moment
need work in order to be able to take
advantage of the new hardware and if we
can do that which is something that
we're actively working on at the moment
we'll be able to take advantage of the
increased power of these systems and the
reduced energy requirements of them in
the next generation but it's a massive
task because we've got codes which have
been developed over a long period of
time and so it's a huge software
engineering task to to rewrite them and
redesign them because it's often it's
not just a case of translating them from
one coding language to another it's
actually redesigning the algorithms
because sometimes the algorithm will
translate directly to a GPU without much
modification
but in most cases it won't so we have to
go through every step of the algorithm
work out which bits can work on only on
a traditional traditional CPU and which
ones can work on an accelerator card and
then we make sure that we port the bits
to the accelerator card but while it's
doing its work we need to have something
for the the CPU to be doing as well so
it's a very fine balance and and a very
large task so we're hoping to set up a
software engineering team with
indie-rock who will be able to take
charge of that for us optimized yes so
the key thing with GPUs and any
accelerators is they're very good at
doing certain types of calculation and
they can do those calculations in
bunches rather than just one at a time
so if you can write your problem as a
set of rep repetitive calculations that
you can just hand over to to the
accelerator card to do done it works
extremely well and it's it's essentially
breaking down the the process that you
are trying to calculate into those steps
which match the capabilities of the GPU
or whatever accelerator card that's the
that's that is that that's a reasonable
analogy and so what we we have to do is
work out we know what the busses can
take and we have to work out how we can
rewrite our algorithms to produce to
have required that kind of calculation
and for some kind of problems there are
natural ways of doing it so those codes
were already in the process of of
modifying but for some problems it may
be that we can't use those kind of
architectures because they're just not
not suitable for us so we're that's what
we're trying to work out now what we're
doing a whole series of benchmarks and
software engineering projects to try and
get that to optimize the codes that we
have yes
so Derek 3 we'll have we expect to have
a component of accelerators we it'll be
it'll vary from machine to machine so
we're again assuming that Derek 3 has
the same basic structure of hovering
several several distributed machines we
would expect some of them will have a
large component of accelerators
others might not because we'll be trying
again to design it around what the
scientists need because that's been the
key strength of the Dirac facility is
it's been designed with the science
questions in mind so each machine is
optimized for a particular type of
science and that's why it's been such a
productive facility we're not just
saying we would like to have a big
computer and then going to the
manufacturers and saying here here is
you know this is the type of computer we
want instead we go to them and we say
this is the type of problem we're trying
to solve what architectures can we use
to solve that problem so it's very much
a process a two-way process where we're
listening to what they can offer and
then we can try to recast some of our
problems in terms as much the hardware
and vice versa so it's usually in terms
of the how connected it is so
essentially each of the individual cores
in the Derek facility is the same as the
cores in your PC at home what makes it a
supercomputer is that those cores are
part of the bigger system so they're all
connected together so as I said earlier
if you just took a thousand home
computers and put them in a room that
wouldn't make them a supercomputer it
would just be a thousand computers in a
room so what makes them a supercomputer
is that they're all connected together
so I can use them as if they were one
big computer and that allows me to do
problem
in maybe a week that would take much
much longer so maybe many months or even
many years if I was trying to do them on
on one of the computers at a time